Donald Trump has been disqualified in
Colorado the Supreme Court has ruled
that Trump under the 14th Amendment
cannot be on the ballot the first thing
that means is the GOP Primary ballot and
of course that will mean the general
election ballot now there's a lot going
into this the ruling is stayed until
January 4th because of appeals but that
doesn't mean anything because they have
90 days I believe Colorado may be
different but typically you have 90 days
to get your your ballots in order for an
election and this means if they do not
have a resolution by that day the 4th
obviously they may actually print
ballots with no Donald Trump the
implications for this are very severe it
could it will jeopardize the GOP Primary
and that may be the key strategy here
Donald Trump has issued a statement
about this the ramaswami has vowed to
remove himself and is calling on all
other candidates to do the same of
course the other more spineless
candidates likely would not